[Music]
good evening I'm Alexander Rose I'm the
executive director here at long now
thank you all for coming out first thing
you may have have noticed that city was
generous enough to sponsor Jonathan
roses book tour and mostly that's been
in bookstores and they were amazingly
generous to sponsor it for everybody
here in the theater so if you have not
gotten the book so far it's out there on
the table and you can get your own copy
tonight of well-tempered City a round of
applause for City thank you yeah in
general it's pretty amazing they're
sponsoring things like this individuals
like Jonathan Rose on these book tours
and it's actually I think a really great
arrangement to really kind of make these
kind of book tours work which they don't
work in the old publishing model so this
is a this is a great model
[Applause]
the long now foundation has says the
long now it's the last 10,000 years the
next 10,000 years based on the concept
that a civilization is about ten
thousand years old and for in the
building story it's another ten thousand
years to think about and civilization
itself is a pretty interesting word in
English because the root is there with
Civic civics citizen City Bank cities
some historians have been saying that
history is what happens in cities and in
this urbanizing century cities are
absolutely of the essence and they
change fast so it's helpful to hear from
somebody who's not only a scholar of the
cities and how they change and how they
might change but has skin in the game as
an actual developer for three
generations in New York City Jonathan
rose Thank You Stewart and it's so
wonderful to be here with many old
friends and some new friends and to be
in the context of the long now and I'm
actually going to start a little bit
before the ten thousand years of history
but we'll get to ten thousand years
pretty quickly we just saw an amazing
film about the Singapore I'm gonna
actually start in Singapore I was in
Singapore first in 1979 and almost all
the buildings you saw in that video did
not exist in 1979 so we've seen enormous
growth and in the 21st century by the
end of the 21st century eighty percent
of the world's population will live in
cities
they're moving to cities for opportunity
but the way we are growing cities
developing cities is out of sync it's
out of sync with nature and we are
destroying nature in a way that is
ultimately unsustainable and it is also
out of sync with our own human nature or
maybe it is with our nature that's
actually a question we're gonna explore
we're seeing increased social variation
income inequality and inequality of
opportunity in the world so as I thought
about all these issues one of the
questions I asked was the question is
how do we find the right path forward
and in thinking about that question just
like long now I began to think first in
the path backwards or how were cities
actually created where did they come
from what was their original purpose
what were their founding principles
because my thought was if we could
understand that maybe we could
understand how to make successful cities
going forward I'm gonna describe nine
seas it happens that as I was figuring
this out every word that seemed to make
sense started with a sea so the nine
seas that I have come to realize were
their preconditions for creating
creating great cities and the first one
is and they come more or less in
sequence actually as you look at cities
developed so the first is cognition
cities are a mental creation cultures of
mental creation and we had as a species
to develop the capacity to think in
certain ways before we could take the
steps that led to being cities these are
Flint's interestingly stones have being
used and carved for as tools for about
third three point three million years in
fact longer than humans
actually pre human species Lucy for
example was thought to have been at a
time when people using stones and and
yet they changed about fifty thousand
years ago was when stones all of a
sudden were attached to sticks to make
arrows to make Spears they're being used
in a different way there was a cognitive
shift that happened fifty thousand years
ago and another thing that's when we
think that language emerged and also
social relations between people and
tribes seem to have changed back then
and so it was a moment of what they
actually called cognitive modernism all
of a sudden emerged and what was
interesting about this time also will
forget that some other things that was
interesting about this time
but they all come from the capacity we
think of human beings all of a sudden
there was a shift in our ability to do
symbolic thinking to think more about
the past and the future to think more
abstractly that actually and we began to
see the manifestation of art we begin to
see the manifestation of religions you
can see this in the way people bury
their either burials took place people
there were no physical structures except
for caves we have no sense that people
were actually building places to live at
that time but there was enormous
cultural flowering happening
the other interesting thing that was
happening then is that humans have
always worked cooperatively there is a
deep tribal instinct within us and
that's actually a strength and a
weakness see the great biologist and
sociobiology Co Wilson has written an
interesting book called the social
conquest of the earth and in this book
he says that this ability of humans to
work together as groups to to hunt and
to share food and to take care of the
weak and to take care of the children
we're the only species that does
something called a low parenting which
is that if you're you know babies crying
somebody else will pick up somebody
else's child and nurture it or maybe
somebody may say I'm doing the cooking
please take care of my child there are
no other species that do that it's a
unique characteristic but it comes
paired with something I was gonna refer
to a little bit earlier and that is we
are both very tribal but we are deeply
wired for the stronger our in group
affiliation the stronger we feel
affection and care and nurturing for
others
simultaneously the stronger out group
hate and so we actually know there's
been no MRI studies we can do that show
that when that when people feel very
deep and loving and compassionate
typically towards a group of people they
simultaneously feel much more angry and
antagonistic towards others those seem
to be wired in our brain we had the
capacity to overcome that but that is
one of our natural propensities another
interesting MRI study
shows that if you give people those
stones I was showing you earlier and you
chip them and you put them in MRI
machine it activates the the language
part of the brain so there is something
about tool making and language that are
also deeply interdependent but all these
became aspects of a cooperative society
we hunted together very very effectively
in fact this human combination of
cooperation and this in-group out-group
we believe may have been the reason that
ultimately humans conquered the
Neanderthals remember the Neanderthals
had bigger brains than us and they may
have even been smarter but they may not
have been nastier and that's an issue we
have to deal with so this is another
piece of cave art I find it really
interesting and this you see this all
over the world people would hold up
their hands up against the wall of the
cave and they'd blow their blow dust out
of their mouths against the hand and
leave these mirror images and to me this
is also a sense of weenus I actually
think that the weenus in which is I'm
going to give you the end of the talk
this weenus in which we are we work
collaboratively we care for others we
take care of others is the cure to our
ills and the part of weenus that comes
paired without group hate that comes
with us against them is actually going
to be what could lead to the end of
civilization but here's a sign there to
me so the question is what I see
interesting within all these images is
this sense that people didn't put up
their hands alone they put them up
collectively I also want to just say
artistically what's so interesting is
notice some of these are in white and
some of these are in black and they had
an amazing sense of like how to compose
this is incredibly contemporary so and
culture keeps advancing so from 50,000
BC culture keeps advancing we're now
that this is probably in the late teens
or 20,000 BC these are the caves in
France really extraordinary art so look
at the work that these people are doing
and that obviously the quality of
thinking is going behind it and they
still haven't built a house
we have no sense that there were
physical structures that they're
creating at that time and then all the
sudden astoundingly 12,500 years ago
this first building is built it's the
first record of a known building now
there could be other buildings that
remember they were all buried we don't
know where they all are
but this is the first one it's in
southern Turkey and it's called gobekli
tepe and it's a temple so what was
interesting is all that time from 50,000
years ago to ten twelve thousand years
ago and and onward to as we'll see what
people were really trying to do is
understand their role in the universe
they were trying to understand what is
this relationship between humanity in
nature who are we where are we and how
do we find harmony and balance back then
the idea of harmony and balance because
remember their work weather variations
there were storms are all kinds of there
were threats there were wild beasts
there were things and the idea of
harmony was deeply deeply important to
them but it's amazing to me that the
first building not only was a temple the
archaeologists who worked on this said
first Kay its name is Klaus Schulze he
said first came the temple then came the
city because what we're going to
discover is that in almost every ancient
city in the world for thousands of years
they were always formed around a temple
there was you dig down down down through
the layers cities that could have
hundreds of thousands of people and when
you get to the very bottom layer there
was a temple that this idea of finding
harmony with the universe of figuring
out where balance was lay at it's very
very core this this building is a
rendering of it and and you see these
huge multi-ton stones that they think it
took five hundred people to carry them
so it took enormous social organization
they're carved with all these amazing
mythic beasts I mean they've the
imagination the skill to create such a
place I had enormous festivals around
these in which they by the way they
slaughtered oxen and ate them and and
they actually believed they probably
took psychedelics so and why this spot
so the the the legends say and
the record says that the reason they
made this spot consecrated the reason
they made this spot holy the reason why
they put this enormous temple there was
because that was the place that the
grains that we're gonna feed
civilization first come from now the
grains that we know know is the ancient
grains that did feed civilization had
not yet actually been to our knowledge
discovered I mean these people
discovered them but they were minor
functions back then there was no
agriculture back then actually but they
actually identified the spot and today
when scientists who followed the
genetics of seeds trace their roots back
they come to 20 miles within this spot
and that is where they say the ancient
seas that fed civilization came from so
who do you think was right the
scientists who thing was 20 miles from
the spotter that guys had built this
thing you thought it was this very spot
I think is this very spot at any rate
there were nine grains that we think are
where the source of civilization and
what was there very interesting is so
what you'll also see throughout the
history the development of cities is the
influence of climate change of
naturally-occurring climate change and
so around 80 200 years ago BC something
like that they the climate got very cold
and and when it did the seeds developed
that the plants to live adapted and for
about a 300 year period they developed a
different characteristic their seeds had
to become much more concentrated because
and the growing season was much shorter
so the ones that drive are the ones that
like shot up got their seed together
grew a big in fat had enough calories in
it to store over the winter and then
we're you know and a hard enough shell
to preserve it then the winter came they
lay dormant and they could grow again
that characteristic of seed happened to
be what dramatically increased the
nutritional and caloric value of seeds
and so civilization grew out of that we
know that there were several different
seeds so einkorn week
this map shows the territories in which
they grew the wild Emmer wheat wild
barley and you actually see they all
come together in this same spot where
the temple was as these seeds grew and
we began to have a fuel for civilization
so calories are the next driver of
remember I'm going through the C's
calories of the next driver we need
energy sources cities so they need
energy sources but back then it was
primaried initially was from from these
grains and all of a sudden you begin to
see now we're in the six thousand seven
thousand five thousand BC you all of a
sudden begin to see in the Fertile
Crescent and the Crescent is this sweep
that goes from the Mediterranean Sea and
down towards the Persian Gulf you see
the emergence of villages these little
villages and the other thing that
happens a couple of thousand years
actually after grains is people start
domesticating animals so you see first
this circle shows where the sheep were
first domesticated and there these are
very ecologically differentiated in
different regions and this is where the
wild goats are done the far right you
know the slide you see is where the
goats came from and here is where the
pigs came from and then a little a
couple thousand years after that they
started domesticating figs and grapes
and olives and all of a sudden you see
the the great Mediterranean diet emerge
but also you see these elements that
really led remember in the Bible h-man
by his fig tree and you could see the
how the domestication of the family
began interestingly by the way when we
see from bone studies that as
domestication happen as people settled
in villages they actually lived shorter
lives they were physically shorter they
they seem to have been unhealthier and
one of the reasons is because when they
lived in the wild they had less exposure
to the diseases that happen when people
live in in groups together and when they
have to deal with their sanitary wastes
and so the dealing of those issues has
actually been for a perennial issue we
know from the plague etc cholera
we know that the management of disease
is a critical element to the
concentration of people
once you had that Network then what was
interesting is you begin to get commerce
because those actually those different
communities began to connect and they
began to trade now the only reason
people trade is if they have something
to trade which means there has to be
differentiation to so what you're
beginning to see all of a sudden we're
not at the city level yet but what
you're seeing is differentiation and
connectivity and interchange and
commerce happening together some morsi's
so this is some of the major trade their
major and minor trade routes and what
they were trading at this point now
we're in the four five thousand BC era
4000 BC they're trading gold and silver
and lapis and copper and alabaster and
bicha men and shelves and and they're
making things and people are
distinguished for making different kinds
of things there's actually one town I
forgot which one it is
they made a pot and it was a pot that
contained grains and they figured out
how to mass-produce it and you can see
it on literally a 1500 mile range you
can see that same pot that was made they
were disposable there was a kind of
disposable container of the time so now
yours having this connectivity so we're
beginning to have those commerce that's
differentiation this connectivity and
that's beginning prosperity and so the
towns are beginning to grow and as they
grow they grow in complexity and so they
are you know we saw the art before the
art then begins to grow in stature and
grow in symbolism and and and require a
higher level of craftsmanship it shows
the complexities of society this by the
way is from the Pergamon museum I'm
going to show you a couple other things
from there too in Berlin an amazing
place if you're ever in Europe it's
really worth seeing you can really see
the roots of civilization there along
with compressive complexity comes the
need for greater systems of control this
is from the tales of Gilgamesh this is
also in the same museum and on the left
side is the god of chaos and on the
right side is the god of control
was trying to control it and that
balance between order and disorder chaos
and control is a key issue to the
formation of cities you cannot have a
large city unless you have a control
system and a key part of control then
becomes rioting and and one of the key
the first parts of writing was actually
numbers or or counting or keeping
records and one of the reasons why is
because I'm going to go back to the
early role of the temple the temple was
one of its roles was to it was the place
that the priest was responsible for
balancing humans in nature a second role
of the priestess was that to mete out
justice he was the respected fair person
that you could trust but a third role
was that the temple became the
storehouses when people started you know
getting a lot of stuff growing a lot of
grain etc they would bring it to the
temple for storage it would be recorded
and there'd be a fair people trusted
that there was a fair distribution in
fact the oldest democratic systems in
the world are the irrigation systems
these go back to about five six thousand
BC so so there's agriculture for
probably three or four thousand years
before there's actually irrigation
there's that they bring a little water
here and there but really sophisticated
irrigation systems the irrigation
systems are the oldest democratic
systems in the world
they're almost and you can see this
whether it's in Asia wherever their
Democratic wherever there are irrigation
systems you see this and the the the
irrigator or is the people who use the
system elect the most trusted person who
is called the ditch boss who is reserve
different names in different cultures
who is responsible for managing the
system for the benefit of all and he or
she is typically would then it was a he
is the one who would say your field is
in the Sun it has a high rate of
evaporation you get some more water and
your field has sandier soil and the
water disappears you get more water or
whatever and people trust that person
and if they don't then they elect
somebody else for the common good so the
priest also played that role
and the counting systems were a way of
keeping tracks are understanding who
contributed what and who is getting what
back out of course it turned into
language and became a much more
sophisticated part of culture okay so
all those things as they begin to build
and build and build we're now about 3200
BC and they end up in a ruk which is the
world's first city it's a pretty
sophisticated city it is of course
formed around at end this is a rendering
were to look we think it looked like as
a formed around a temple was formed
around so that remember that idea of a
temple which is a place of justice it's
a place of the fair distribution of
goods it's a place of finding harmony
between humans in nature it's a place of
control between the forces of chaos and
the forces of centrality in society so
that is it the basis of Luke said the
base of every city every village that
was created before Luke and it's the
basis for thousands of years of cities
after a route interestingly by the way
when the first cities were formed there
was not war there may have been local
conflicts but the idea of war actually
in conquering war lands only appeared
about 500 years later this is also from
the program in museum and you can just
imagine this facade which which lined
thousands of feet of wall these kind of
carved sculptures and that were
plastered and colored and all that stuff
so this is Hammurabi so now we're about
1790 BC Hammurabi is the king of
Babylonia and he has conquered many many
people's and he comes up with this
extraordinary code and the code is how
shall we live who shall we be I'm gonna
give you a quote from from his quote and
you it's really worth googling it and
reading the whole thing he says when
marm duke mar duke that was the great
god sent me to rule over men to give
protection of the right to the land i
did right and righteousness and brought
about the well-being of the oppressed he
saw his role is bringing about the
well-being of the pervy oppressed
the great gods have called me I am the
salvation bearing shepherd the good
shadow that has spread over my city in
my shelter I have let them repose in
peace that the strong may not injure the
weak in order to protect the widows and
offer orphans in order to speak justice
in the land to settle disputes to heal
all injuries I shall rule to further the
well-being of mankind this was the role
of leadership it's a role by the way
that I don't think many of our leaders
aspire to today but that sense of that I
have power I've been given power but I
have my power comes with responsibility
my power has a purpose to bring about
the well-being of the oppressed so that
the strong may not injure the weak in
order to protect the widows and orphans
in order to defeat justice in the land
to heal all injuries what an amazing
premise for civilization and the code of
hammurabi was then put on Collins
beautifully carved columns and spread
throughout his city and cities and one
of the reasons we believe that happened
was because he had conquered many
peoples and they all came this was not
the first coat but they all had their
own local codes they all had local
ecologically and culturally evolved ways
of being and he needed a more universal
one and so he created this and spread
around so to unify diversity into a
single purpose and I believe that is
actually another great thing that a city
can do when a city has a vision but has
a sense of higher purpose and it
embraces the diversity that would this
within it it's not asking the diversity
to change but it is asking the the
diversity become coherent about some
higher value I think that really is what
makes great cities so just quickly to
review we have seen cognition
cooperation culture calories
connectivity commerce complexity I
forgot to mention concentration but
simply density that the we've talked
about diversity but it all needs to be
concentrated with
to spread out we saw that happen in the
great decades of sprawl in the United
States you lose the energy that happens
from the cohesion of people being
together concentration and control so
these sees it strikes near the necessary
preconditions for the formation of
cities the the very original cities and
I believe they are the necessary
preconditions for thriving cities in the
future the two interesting pathways that
cities took an Eastern one and a western
one which I'm just going to briefly
discuss this is the Greek temple and in
Greece you remember Greek philosophy one
of the first things that they looked for
was what was the atom and what was the
essential core underlying characteristic
of things what was the you know the very
nature of things and they viewed it as
an individual thing this you could
reduce everything down to this essence
of the atom so we have a very individual
focused Western culture we we think
strongly of ourselves and who we are
there was another culture though oh by
the way so one of the things that came
out of that well it was out of that
sense of individuality was incredible
entrepreneurship and creativity so I
view that a a progenitor of or a
follower of the great Greek culture was
what happened in Florence imagine this
one square mile of a city in the 1400s
gave birth to the entire Renaissance
gave birth to so much of the arts and
culture literature of what became modern
Europe it was all so much we grew out of
just that one mile what that teaches us
also is that our cities if we capture
our creativity well can be incredibly
generative places but there was another
grain that also fueled civilization and
that was rice and actually there's very
some interesting studies this is the
rice area of China above it was also a
wheat area and some people there's a
whole theory about rice people versus
wheat people and that they have
different cultures and all that which
I'm not entirely sure I believe so I
won't go into the theory but any rate
cultures of northern China and southern
China are quite different China followed
an entirely different pattern in
developments very early on same thing
their villages are towns there's their
buildings were always centered first
there was a temple and we see that by
the way in South America we see that
almost wherever civilization emerged but
the and also the role their temple was
to find the harmony between heaven and
earth
that was that was this point it was
always built around sacred places but
they had a very quickly they came upon
you know about Chinese Feng Shui and
geomancy they came up with a very
structured idea and that was that the
universe followed this nine square
pattern in which everything would be
divided in nine squares in in the center
which is number five in this diagram was
where the power spot was that's where
the Emperor's stayed that's where the
Emperor's Palace should be that's the
the leverage point to achieve this
balance between humans in nature so when
they divided fields their fields would
all be mapped into nine and each farmer
would have a square numbers one through
nine except number five then they would
do that they would harvest that for
themselves they would collectively
harvest the center square they'd take
the grains from that center square and
it would go to the village center where
we beast that village center was
designed in nine squares and they would
take all the grains get stored in the
Emperor's building which was in the
center square that would go to a
regional town and same thing the center
was where administration and storage was
it'll go all the way up until you hit
the capital city this happens in
Forbidden City which is built much much
later than in Beijing but the it's also
built on the nine square principle
literally from about 2000 BC until the
1600s maybe even a little later every
single farm town regional centers small
city large city in China was designed
around the same nine square principle
this name form and it was all to align
and that all added up
one great centralized place where the
Emperor lived in the Emperor's job was
to balance humans and nature he was to
hold the who is the holder of the
Harmony he was responsible for harmony
and if he failed that's when we got a
new emperor
so what's very interesting about this is
that just as there was this master plan
in effect very early master plan that
affected all of Chinese civilization
there was this sense enormous sense that
we're all in it together so I mentioned
earlier how the Greeks had the sense of
individuation the Chinese has this sense
of collectiveness this great sense of
the great flow the propensity of all
things the DAO the wit but it was all
about being together there was a very
little sense of individual expression in
the Chinese culture from those thousands
of years much more of a sense of a
collective sense of whole I actually
believed that the solutions of the 21st
century required us to draw from both of
these that our Western culture has
become too selfish and too self-centered
and I the eastern culture has actually
changed dramatically it's not what it
originally was but we need to find the
place in between we're going to talk a
little bit about that so let's talk
about where we are in the 21st century
the world is rapidly urbanizing its
urbanizing in an almost brutal way in
most places a lot of building a lot of
housing a lot of concrete and steel
being used
none of the thought that actually went
into the building of cities though the
kind of thought about finding harmony
and balance between humans in nature
there we saw so many thousands of years
ago the population is dramatically
growing by the 2050 demographers say we
will stabilize at a population of about
10 billion people the population is also
growing more middle classes growing
wealthier this is a good thing because
we have fewer and fewer people in abject
and absolute poverty but what's
happening is as people grow more
prosperous they consume more
and with 10 billion people the rate of
consumption versus the rate of the
Earth's capacity to regenerate is going
out of balance and our consumption is
not only about basic needs but has
become really about it
and a sense of there's a lot of
entertainment and perhaps a lot of
excess going on in all this the same
time the climate is changing this time
because of human there's some very
interesting things that by the way
happen to history when the climate
changes throughout history but I won't
go into all that but a climate change
you see dramatically affecting the rise
and fall of cities throughout history
but this is human-caused climate change
and we do need to find a better way I
love this picture because here we are in
Tiananmen Square in Beijing and the air
as you can see that's what it is a
typical Chinese day but they have this
huge TV screen of trying to convince
people that somewhere in China the air
is actually really good so we've also
seen with climate change that were
having tourists shifts in weather
patterns dryness and so we're seeing
fires potato California's experienced
some terrible ones recently and yet also
terrible snows in the winter so we're
seeing some weather extremes are seeing
blackouts as is hurricane sandy and as I
mentioned with the weather patterns
changing we're seeing dramatically
increased droughts and we have been
developing in many of the wrong places
so we are growing our buildings in the
places exactly where there's not going
to be enough water and all of this is
characterized the military in the late
1990s came up with a phrase called a
VUCA which stands for a volatility
uncertainty complexity and ambiguity we
were in a VUCA age things are extremely
volatile and what that means is that
things are less certain and when you're
in a complex system where everything is
interwoven together there is a specific
input has an unspecific or an ambiguous
output so it's very hard to do strategic
planning is very hard to kind of
understand where we are and where we're
going in our traditional rat
mind we actually need to think
differently we have enormous financial
volatility I don't remember but a couple
years ago the Greek always sees B AB and
the Greek bonds are about to default and
when and there were about 300 billion
dollars of bonds that are going to
default on about half of them so say a
hundred and fifty billion dollars of
bonds were going to default and the
stock market went down by about three
trillion dollars so why people who own
stocks didn't even own the Greek bonds
in most cases because the financial
systems are deeply interconnected and
this thing about VUCA this thing about
complexity is you get leverage effects
so we are living in this age in which we
are much more exposed to volatility and
uncertainty and I actually think that
pervades a lot of the political issues
of our time is that people don't know
where they stand or the world around
them seems unstable in 2011 there were
all of a sudden riots in London it
seemed to make no sense where do these
riots come from this is a Google map as
to where the rides took place the deeper
the red on the map the deeper the
poverty and if you look at where the
little legal points are where the riots
took place they didn't take place in the
most poor neighborhoods he actually took
place on the edges where the lower
middle class the middle class mean they
took places where the into the invisible
line of income inequality and political
inequality and opportunity those
invisible lines that are actually in
every society and PBS it was not good it
was the second-generation immigrants the
children the young teens who felt that
they just there was no where more to go
and we're seeing that is actually that
sense of of invisible line that is
holding us back is permeates significant
parts of America and parts of the world
and then the last thing is we have these
terrible wars this is in Syria it's
actually it's a whole other talk with
it's also war that started with climate
change and there today in the world 60
million refugees and I'm sure that there
are more to come
enormous displacement I mean here we are
in the
first century it's a time in which we
should be building the greatest cities
that we can and we're destroying some of
the greatest cities in history and I
won't go on about that but uh so there
are a lot of issues in the 21st century
that we need to confront and this is a
quote from Kenneth Burke in 1935 people
may be unfitted being fit into an on
people maybe unfitted by being fit in an
unfit Fitness I know it sounds like a
funny phrase but so I think a lot in
evolutionary terms and remember Darwin's
survival the fittest but what he really
meant was the strongest fittest but
those who fit together the best the
ecological fitness fit the fittest and
so we're in a time in which we have a
fitness we do there is a fitness that
you know we have societies we have
systems we have financial systems
political systems and all that that work
in a small ecological zone but they are
unfit for the larger challenges of our
tone and so the quest for this book that
I was writing my quest by about cities
Mike my question was how do we find the
true Fitness that we as human beings and
human civilization needs so that we can
thrive where we all can have well-being
in the 21st century and as I was writing
and I did a lot of research and writing
I would this book actually started with
a different title and but I would listen
to the music of Bach and and I fell in
love with the his this piece the
well-tempered clavier and it all of a
sudden struck me that the idea of
temperament which is transformational in
the history of music could actually be a
transformational idea also for the
challenges that I was trying to deal
with so we're gonna go back a little bit
in history Pythagoras about lived about
2000 BC and 2500 BC and and he came up
with this idea I'm sorry I got the
numbers right he lived 500 BC thank you
it's 2,500 years ago he lived 500 BC
he came up with this idea of the music
of the spheres he noticed that they
different the spaces between the notes
and a liar or lute were exactly the same
as the distance between the planets and
by the way pretty amazing he could
measure the distance between the planets
but in fact he was right and he said
that this is a proportion it's the
golden proportion and that it exists
throughout all the universe and you
could see and by the way this proportion
exists much in nature and he said so
that's the way everything should be
organized if you want to find harmony
you design things to this proportion by
the way there are other parts of nature
that are not designed in this proportion
but it is a very prevalent quality of
nature and it was a good idea
by meanwhile so this is McKeith Agra's
teaching and the woman looking askance
is of course his wife her name was a
philosopher named piano and what she
said is she proposed an idea called the
golden mean so he had the golden ratio
share the gold meaning which she said
was not everything has to be so perfect
there's compromise and sometimes the
space in between where two extremes meet
is actually where true harmony is in the
issue of music she turned out to be
right so what was happening was as long
as you were playing alone and in one key
the perfection of tuning which so from
pythagoras on everybody just tune their
instruments in the Pythagorean way and
that worked but if you tried to move
between keys it turns out that although
each key was perfect in its own right
they were improved they were slightly
out of joint with each other and they
said it actually excruciating to listen
to and so music the Western musical
canon was actually limited until this
idea came from China a Chinese scholar
actually figured out this problem and
figured out the math of a different kind
of tuning system it came along the Silk
Route came into Europe in the late 1600s
1687 guy named Andres worked Meister who
came up with the new tuning was called
well temperament or even temperament and
that all of a sudden allowed one to go
between key
to integrate all the keys in in what
actually became a new technology the
clear which we'll see in a minute
and this Unleashed Bach to be able to
create the well-tempered clavier it
unleashed him to be able to integrate
every note and every key in scale into
an extraordinary magnificent piece of
music Bach was a deeply religious man
and he wrote for the church and his
mission was to take the architecture of
the universe as he understood it all of
its glory and magnificence but also its
humility his compassion and to take this
and to manifest it on music on earth and
although these notes are written to the
same when you play them today they're
the same those that we played three four
hundred years ago but you can see the
sweep the arc the kind of sense of
movement within them and each time that
movement comes alive and he was able to
do that because of this concept of
temperament which found a way to
integrate all these different components
of music so I view that as temperament
is an operating system and the this is
the covere which is the forerunner of
the piano and that was like a new
technology and when we have new
operating systems and new technologies
and we put them together and we get new
opportunities and again we are at at
that time in history where those are
both available to us so we're gonna get
it a little bit into how we might use
them but before we do I want to talk
about the bottom of the different
different before we get to integration
we're going to talk about
differentiation and where some of our
environmental and social problems come
from in 1970 the Congress passed a law
called NEPA the National Environmental
Protection Act and it had extraordinary
aspirations so I'm just going to read a
little bit Congress recognizing the
profound impact of man's activity on
interrelations of all components of the
natural environment particularly the
profound influences of population growth
high density urbanization industrial
expansion resource explain exploitation
new and expanding technologies and
recognizing the critical
Horton's of restoring and maintaining
environmental quality to the overall
welfare and development of man declares
the continuing policy of federal
government to create and maintain the
conditions under which man and nature
can exist in productive harmony and
fulfill the social economic and other
requirements of present and future
generations of Americans this was a
bipartisan bill was signed by Republican
President Richard Nixon this was weird
the American consensus was at that time
and here we are more than 40 years later
and it feels to me like we have gone
backwards but to have a bill in which
all of Congress said we want to create
and maintain the conditions under which
man in nature can exist in productive
harmony to fulfill the social economic
and other requirements of present and
future generations what a lofty ambition
but unfortunately the way it was
manifested was through this that NEPA
requires that we did vast environmental
impact statements and these took major
problems and they subdivided them into
minor problems and they are they
actually forced us to disintegrate the
way that we think so I'm going to give
you a an analogy for how to pull these
back together and it begins with
something called bio complexity so in
bio complexity what's very interesting
is there is a meta genome for example if
you go to a river they'll be you can
find the genomics of the entire river
you can find the genome that has the
fish has the plants how that's why
they're all integrated this is why when
humans breathe in oxygen and breathe out
carbon dioxide and trees do the opposite
why we're all tied together as from this
meta-genome of life we can so using that
as a thought process it became clear to
me that if our cities started with a
great vision and then they move forward
with a plan and then we establish
community health indicators we'll see
what those are but ways to understand
where we are we mean we use the tools of
government regulation investment
incentives we measure the outcomes week
pair those to the indicators so just the
way nature's continually Co evolving and
it has this genome that's tying it all
together we can be doing that's a
different way of planning than we did
under NEPA but we can be doing that too
this is a vision that the people of
Portland through the Portland Saints
sustainability Institute came up with
and you can see in this vision there's
locally grown food there's taller
buildings for them that's a higher
density buildings they're green
buildings they have windows on the roof
in this street you see buses and people
walking in bicycles and streetcars and
automobiles you can see it's there's
parks on the left side of there's
diversity on the right side that they
have one vision they now know where
they're going as a city we can measure
these things we can identify the
characteristics of those if you this
happens to be Santa Monica many many
cities have these sustainability or
community health indicators so if you
look around the chart we'll have how
much affordable housing do we have how
poor is our climate impacts how well are
our students doing in school how is our
health we can measure hundreds of that
we can identify hundreds of these
factors and then we can move dynamically
we can control our systems too and we
can use the tools the government have
which are investments in infrastructure
regulation incentives that they use to
continuously move towards the outcomes
that we seek and this has those outcomes
have to be done designed through a
community-based planning process I'm
gonna skip a couple things because I can
see I'm running out of time the next
step is we need to take our
infrastructure systems which are linear
systems so we have designed an entire
society in which for example most cities
in America takes stuff in and 180 days
later 98 percent of his left is waste we
need to design circular systems where we
take things in and we recycle them so
I'll give you some examples of this this
is the water treatment plant in Wynne
hook which is the capital of Namibia
Namibia is a desert city in southern
Africa its population was growing it was
running out of water 40 years ago an
engineer said we should judge water by
its quality and not by its history they
took the wastewater they cycled it back
and use it as fresh water and for 40
years they have never had a failure
they said the system has worked
perfectly and so the city has grown and
has grown to prosperity we need to be
doing this in our desert areas we've
been moving forward by the way there's a
new plant waste treatment plant that
just opened up in the Washington area
that is also taking out the nitrogen and
the phosphorus which are components of
fertilizer from the urine in the
wastewater it is taking those out for
$100 a ton it is selling those for $400
a ton to fertilizer manufacturers we now
have waste plants that capture all the
methane that comes off of them and not
only burns that to create enough energy
to fuel the plant but it also fuels the
neighborhoods around them so the waste
plants are becoming factories so imagine
if we took every part of our urban
system and took it from being linear to
to cyclical and turned it into
regenerative factories where we were
creating local jobs we were reducing the
impact on the environment we're creating
more prosperity and well-being and this
can be done as centralized ways and it
can be done distributed so we can
collect rainwater from roof so we can
collect solar on roofs this is the
Bullitt Center in Seattle which is a
building designed as a living building
standard in which collects more sunlight
and rain water than it uses imagine if
you then took buildings like that and
began to connect them into micro grids
into systems where they were sharing not
only their water and their energy but
their their waste heat they were tied
together so that and connecting that you
do need base load also but with fuel
cells and with you know cogeneration and
wind and wind power and solar power all
tied together then which you can begin
to create as is much more connected
networks just like the first
civilizations were much more connected
and what's great about that is that when
one link goes out and other if you
create smart systems another one can
take over it's called self-healing
equates remember we're talking about
enormous volatility in the twenty
for centuries so it creates much more
flexibility we can begin to bring nature
back into our cities and all kinds of
levels and we have found that as
restorative people and restorative of
place - this is again a shot of
Singapore Singapore is by the way said
now we can bring the nature back in city
but it has to be bio diverse so they're
a big focus on planning a wide range of
species and we now know that bringing
nature back to our river's edge and our
water fronts is a key part of resilience
to rising sea levels and climate change
I want to talk about the resilience of
people one of the themes that's very
very important to me America I believe
was founded as a land of opportunity and
that opportunity is poorly distributed
and becoming more and more poorly
distributed and we now know what the
constitutive a Sui can see by zip code
we know that their zip codes in which
some people will live 15 years longer
than others we know zip codes about
wealth with clothes about health
outcomes education outcomes and yet we
know what the constituents of
opportunity are and we know how to make
them place-based and local it starts
with affordable housing this is really
critical I have a friend named Rhonda
Williger who says it's very hard to do
home work when you live under a bridge
people need safe green affordable
housing maybe great education systems
Finland that's the best education system
in the world every school is equally as
good whether it's in the wealthiest
neighborhood the poorest neighborhood
the most finished neighborhood the most
immigrant neighborhood they're all the
same we need that in America we need
great health care parks and open space
neighbors serving markets arts and
sculpture mass transit ultimate multiple
transit options to tie together jobs and
we need what I also what were part of
that key part of the essential growth of
initial cities that seed of a national
cities something spiritual that ties us
gives us a sense of our place in the
universe these components by the way we
can measure them just as I showed you
with the community health indicators we
can see where we are we can design our
cities we can design our neighborhoods
and communities we can invest
in them we can invest in the human
infrastructure physical infrastructure
to achieve these and one of the most
important things we need to do is to
grow the social infrastructure in 1997
there was a great heatwave in Chicago
and almost nine over nine hundred people
died a sociologist named Eric Klinenberg
mapped where they died and what he
discovered was the the wealthy white
neighbor has had a much lower death rate
than the poor black neighborhoods but
there were two poor black neighborhoods
that outperformed the white
neighborhoods and the reason why was
they had a very strong very compassion
day social networks growing out of
churches in which the elderly were
checked on every day these networks
existed long before the heatwave
but when the volatility came when the
heatwave came that had built the
community muscle of interconnection and
that is what saved people's lives and
that sense of human connection and
compassion I believe is a key part of
our resilience needed in the 21st
century there's a disease that is
affecting our children that is affecting
all of us called aces stands for adverse
childhood experiences and aces abuse its
family dysfunction and neglect and so
for example if a parent a child is in a
room where there is domestic violence
taking place if they are evicted from a
home if they are physically or sexually
abused whole series of these these three
categories of abuse dysfunction and
neglect it deeply affects the child and
that the child experiences four or more
by the time they are three it rewires
their brain it puts them in the
permanent fight/flight mode so that when
they're young they're in the recessive
flight mode and so when they're in
school they can't pay attention because
their brain is always looking for the
next threat even if it hasn't happened
for a couple of years and they can't
form social relations because they don't
trust anybody and when they become a
teenager they move into the fight mode
high-risk behavior and high teenage
pregnancy we now know this is deeply
tied to disease Kaiser Permanente's
started this with a study of 17,000
and the San Diego area by the way mostly
people who are white college educated in
suburban and what they discovered was
that if you had four more aces you would
have two hundred thirty six percent more
chance of arthritis higher chance of
asthma has cancer diabetes heart attack
so this disease has huge this social
cost that also has so this is just a
physical side obviously has mental
health sides much higher rates of
suicide much higher rates of a school
dropout etc and it leads to twenty years
if you have six or more aces than at
least a twenty years less in life so
this is a disease that is that is
becoming more prevalent in this modern
and complex and volatile age and it's
one that I believe is might be one of
the keys of multi-generational poverty
and I believe it is also perhaps a key
to the lack of sense of commonality that
our nation is facing has enormous
economic tolls it cost one hundred and
twenty four billion dollars a year for
each child year that means all the
four-year-olds now who suffer from aces
throughout their life will cost society
one hundred and twenty four billion
dollars and the next year the new
four-year-olds will cost aside one
hundred twenty four billion and on and
on it is not good we know there are
solutions we know that and they are
mixture of so we know that meditation
actually really helps it actually
rewires the brain takes us out of our
emotional center we know yoga helps
because traumas embodied cognitive
behavioral therapy is essential San
Francisco by the way is the leader in
something called trauma-informed care
much of this work by the way came from
the extraordinary work of a doctor in
San Francisco working in the Hunters
Point area
her name is dr. Nadine Burke Harris and
she has really shown how we need to
bring affordable housing managers family
doctors family therapists the school
system and the family itself all
together and when we do that we can
actually address this issue she's doing
amazing work and the city as I said is a
real leader in
thinking about how to solve these
problems in its public housing the other
thumb I'm going to skip all this and
just the last point is that that we
don't address this well in the United
States we spend far too much on the
symptom which is health care this is how
much we spend on health care and you'll
see the far left is these are all the
OECD nations America spends by far the
most this is what the other nations
spend so you see many were in the middle
many of the nations spend more than us
when you combine spending on health care
and spending on affordable housing and
prenatal care on mental health on social
services on high quality education when
you actually spend those you can spend
much less on health care because you're
solving the problems you create a more
equitable society create greater
societal well-being if you remember back
to the very beginning the role of the
priest was to oversee the fair
redistribution of societal benefits for
the benefit of all and this to me seems
to be one of the access points so in
summary it seems to me there there are
three things that we need to be doing
we deeply need to be integrating humans
in nature in our cities our cities are
gonna get more dense as they get more
dense we can make them smarter and
greener and bring nature back into them
we need to imbue them with compassion I
actually believe that compassion is that
missing Fitness it is altruism is our
adaptive solution it is the pathway
forward it is the great integrator it is
the place in which we think of we rather
than me it is that place of balance in
which I think the best of human society
can move forward we need to actually
have symbols of that we need to actually
take these ideas that the extraordinary
beauty and harmony of nature which bakka
so deeply understood and the compassion
that we also that our religious leaders
have taught us and there have been keys
to part of our civilization we need to
combine these into actually the places
that we build and I want to end with a
quote from Christopher Alexander a birth
based architect who says making
wholeness heals the maker as we dedicate
ourselves to creating whole places that
kills us - it is a regenerative making
wholeness is a regenerative act and that
is what I hope you'll go forward and do
thank you
[Applause]
Johnson they um a little bit of the skin
in the game angle here yeah
third-generation real estate in a
red-hot city like Manhattan is pretty
interesting see a little bit about
third-generation see a little bit about
being a real estate person now got it so
I grew up in a wonderful family of
developers people with enormous
integrity my family's handshake was as
good as a contract they built market
rate rental buildings primarily some
affordable housing where primarily
that's what they built in New York and
they spread a little around the East
Coast I would ever I was a child of the
60s deeply ruled by civil rights people
he moved by the environmental world and
I wanted I I deeply believe that one
could integrate a social mission and
environmental mission in a for-profit
format and what did your family think of
that and my family they were they're
very generous and good-hearted people
with it they felt business was business
and philanthropist philanthropy so in
1989 I left the family company and
started my own company it's a mission
based for-profit one of the things very
clear is it unless we make projects that
are profitable no one's gonna copy them
and so actually the first project we did
was in downtown work all over the
countries in downtown Denver I took a
full city block an old department store
called the Denver dry goods building was
a time in which people were moving out
of the city cities were emptying and
make a long story short we came up with
a model for how to make it green
actually you work with a Emery love is
the Rocky Mountain Institute on that
part how to make a green mixed income
mixed-use historic preservation
transitory and development it was
everything and it was incredibly
successful the city took that model and
within three years 23 other buildings in
downtown Denver were renovated with the
same model it's one of the key things of
whether there's a thriving City now that
brought people back to the city so part
of the mission of my company is to do
things to do them first to do them well
to create new models but they got to
work so they can be duplicated one of my
goals in this book is that have
is big in ideas I can have but everyone
has to be held to my developers test it
has to actually be implementable and
financeable or it's not gonna grow so
Adam asks is someone with experience and
development how do we encourage private
developers to build and plan in ways
that are good for the collective must
all be done with regulation by national
regional government or inspiration or
what well they make more money doing
that well so it's it's a combination of
all those things first of all I'm a big
believer in regulation I hate regulation
so I believe in building codes I believe
in zoning codes I believe in a lot of
the regulation that is for the common
good that goes back to hammer rabbi I
also find I'm stuck with a lot of
unnecessary and frustrating and
ridiculous the rabbi said if you built a
house on that Street you will be I guess
crucified as I recall it on the street
no no but he didn't I don't remember
that part but I definitely know as he
said here's the building code if your
building falls down and kills somebody
we kill you right I proved to be very
that proved to be very effective
building codes so at any rate we do need
good regulations we also need incentives
we also need government to make
investments I love the fact that the
state of California is doing high-speed
rail we need we need investments in
climate adapting solutions we need to
create the frame but we also need to do
a change in culture I was one of the
first there were others too who built
green affordable housing and when I
started people thought I was nuts we
have changed the culture of affordable
housing and so now certainly in the Bay
Area all new affordable housing is being
built green and although throughout much
of the country so industries have
cultural practices too and as good
models are done the industry is evolved
so that you move the norms and then the
norms going in this direction and they
keep going in that direction absolutely
keep pushing the edge or you can totally
keep pushing the edge and we see we
actually see a lot of positive certainly
in the green building side we're seeing
enormous
continuous advancement continuous
improvement and we seen interest be
really interested in continuous
improvement also so we've had previous
San Francisco mayor here and one of the
questions that came up there is he said
that San Francisco pays very close
attention to Vancouver to Portland it
feels kind of competitively them trying
to get greener than their how the cities
learn from each other they just at
visiting mayors or the real estate guys
go from town to town taking green things
happen other cities are doing an amazing
job of learning from each other
it's something that by the way nations
and congress's could do but cities are
they function in a realm we call
coopertition they're all competing for
more jobs and and prestige but they
their networks such as the sea for T or
C 60 now the same or remotely see 40 to
60 I guess is well beyond 60 now was
that was so that's something that uh I
don't remember who initially founded
Bloomberg was probably in that one you
didn't found it but he sponsors that it
has taken over but there there are many
national and global organizations Italy
is another one which helps cities share
best practices mm-hmm and cities are
very generous in doing they also see
this export business so for example the
city of Rotterdam now views itself as
the leading exporter of solutions to
rising sea level and it has a whole
engine that the the government actually
promotes its engineers who were the best
in the world of this and they are very
very good at it but cities are very open
about sharing solutions why why do you
think that why is that not its it work
so well with other entities states or
nations Wi-Fi cities its cities have
this business and they they're more
cooperative than competitive what's
going on they're competitive as I said
they're cooperative we can be it's not
black and white we can be cooperative
and end competitive but there is a
flourishing of new ideas we're really
seeing an amazing
I think that's 60s 70s and 80s were kind
of the low point in city history and
we're now seeing we haven't at the high
point yet but we're seeing an enormous
flourishing of ideas and exchange going
on is and and willingness to learn from
each other
are you international in your activities
now versus all you wish I'm primarily US
but I do do consulting and advisory work
internationally one of the most
interesting things I did was work in Sao
Paulo on creating an affordable housing
plan so I mean the scholarship for this
book was considered a lot of it was
books and stuff were you traveling and
visiting places and picking up cool
ideas absolutely we're best what was
most exciting actually I'd say the most
exciting thing I I came this is a place
I have not been but that I read so in
1990 the city of Medellin and I remember
this in 1990 was considered the most
dangerous city in the world there was
huge amount of drug the drug cartels
were there it was a brutal violent place
in 2013 it was voted the greenest most
sustainable city in the world
how did that happen in 23 years that
they completely transformed the culture
of the city they treated and they
literally they they took a pathway that
surrounded the city that had been called
the path of death it's where the drug
dealers would hang the bodies to stake
their territory and it's now the path of
life is surrounded by preserved land and
community gardens usually that happens
with one mayor that gets just an office
because he or she is doing the right
thing that happened there so that
happened there but it also happens by
building this is why a key is this sense
that we're all in it together you know I
talked about we have a culture today of
personal maximization and what we really
need is a culture of systems
optimization when the system is
optimized and all its components do well
that's really what ecology is that's
that that's the pathway of nature and I
believe the cities that focus on
optimization of the whole for everybody
are the ones that thrive the best David
Margolick
do cities need mythologies of their own
in part from all these seas what are the
communities of different cities myths
and more about this urban mythology and
temple and spirituality and you know
this can get a little - huggy pretty
quickly what are we talking about here
so so I well so for example
Saskatchewan's motto is we're the potage
capital of the world
po cash capital of the world right I
don't think that gets you far you know I
don't think that creates the community
spirit that advances you versus Medellin
which said we are the city of life and
they take every child's life seriously
they take and by the way other than
saying we're the Big Apple I don't think
New York has a motto I don't know if San
Francisco has work work if they're just
a little song about it in the ER agent
so so I actually think having a common
ethos and a sense of who we are and
where we're all going collectively is
very important don't cities they've been
around for a while kind of fall into a
mess whether they want to or not I think
all institutions that have been around
for a while
tend to fall into a myth about their
self-importance so if that's the case
then presumably part of what a well
tempered City will do will acknowledge
the myth that has built up around it
right and you know Los Angeles were the
world capital of entertainment whatever
it may be
well San Francisco we just horse around
and sometimes things get interesting
and he'll identify the the most sort of
inspiring aspect of the mythology or
there's growing in it anyway and then
leverage that into cool things I think
leveraging city strengths is really
important understanding what they're and
but there's another key part which is to
make sure that the benefits of it are
equally distributed and in the book I
did an interesting thing where I
analyzed the the equality of the city
the prosperity GDP of the city and the
well-being of the city and you can see
the best cities are the ones where those
are are the most equal or the most in
balance with each other
I think that's III think that sense of
environmental balance and human and
social balance and care is really
important to the thriving of cities what
we see by the way throughout history is
that whenever there is population growth
overconsumption of resources and then
climate change hits mm-hmm if there's
income inequality the city collapses
we've got some cities with serious
inequality REO comes to mind right oh
squatter cities and so on and one of the
things that cities do is develop their
own internal economics right and when
you have both wealthy people and poor
people in the same city often slammed
right up against each other like in Rio
and Sao Paulo and so on you've got
people with too much money and not
enough time people not have money but a
lot of time they goes with it you know
not having work and the one hires the
other and in in Rio the the maids and
the guards and the drivers and the
nannies and so on walked to work from
the Salam over here to the wealthy
mansions just down the street
that sounds economically not so bad so
first of all I don't believe that poor
people have a lot of time is actually
it's hard work being poor dancer is it
there's a lot of hard work being [ __ ]
yep and the though you described the
beginnings of an integration I'll go
back to Medellin one of the amazing
things they did was they said these poor
people are isolated there in hillsides
or in slums
how we gonna connect them the roads are
too we can't put some rosen's of too
steep what city what they put in ski
lifts they took Swiss ski gondolas and
put them in Medellin it's incredible and
all of a sudden they unleashed all those
people from the slums so they could get
the jobs and at the places where the ski
let's land in schools and libraries
that's cool
that's seriously easy San Francisco has
Hills we can right okay so Cece Huang
says you mentioned the problems caused
by income inequality and portable
housing issue in every city and boy is
it big in San Francisco right now
because the median income or something
has been going up and and it's making
working and living here unless you're
gonna unicorn hard what's the solution
please okay so first I get the [ __ ] I'm
gonna define the problem a little more
mmm-hmm it costs seven hundred thousand
dollars in San Francisco didn't build a
new affordable housing apartment that's
the most expensive in the country so
it's got to be subsidized or what has to
be subsidized but we'll get to that in a
minute and for the average apartment
rent today in San Francisco you one
needs an income of one hundred and sixty
thousand dollars a year to be able to
only spend thirty percent of your income
on housing so you haven't in so there's
only one solution to this and that is
you have to build your way out of it and
you you know you need more affordable
housing it has to be built and that in
San Francisco makes it very hard to
build so so the innocent people's
backyards ever highriser so you need
density and you need density in all
kinds of ways what's interesting in that
second last image or third to last image
I showed you because of a very green
city that was much taller what you X
which in our goodness that's who the
Singapore Singapore is done an amazing
job of this that
as you build higher density all of a
sudden you create more mass transit more
cost-effectively you make more
connectivity more walkability and you
can actually create more preserved open
space and that is the bargain the
bargain is higher density of which so in
New York City now new law but 30% of all
new development essentially has to be
affordable and so you you need to create
more mixed income housing we don't want
to create ghettos and remember if if
under $160,000 a year you can't afford
housing in in San Francisco well I'm not
talking about for homeless I'm talking
about for people who have jobs and are
hard-working
we need to create more mixed income
housing we need to create higher density
connected with more transit systems and
at the same time find the space to
create more parks and open space so
you've got a lot of high rollers and
Hudson Yards and places like this and
they're building ever more elite
multi-million dollar condos that are
empty most of the time Raj doesn't
exactly add to the fabric of the city
should that be regulated against or so
and and carve the money off of that use
it for something else sure what so two
different there's two answers to that so
first of all in New York City the tax
code and all the incentives were aligned
so that in the rental side this was not
taking care of a little condo side but
it's now going to be but on the rental
side the most profitable way to build is
what something called 8020 thousand
twenty percent affordable 80 percent
market rate if you look at the standard
apartment building that any for-profit
developers building in New York City
almost every one of them is 20 percent
affordable does the incentives work that
way and it works fantastically well it
has not been enough to house we have a
huge affordable housing issue in New
York too but that kind of what's called
inclusionary building is is one of the
key paces to start the other thing about
it we've done this you have done 80/20
yes I have one that's gonna start
construction in a couple weeks
and by the way work out financially for
you as I said it's designed the whole
program is designed so it's just
slightly better so then that's why I
said home you
the almost every new rental building
they built since the 1980s in New York
City has been built under this program
because it made economic sense it was
not designed for the condo market but it
was designed for the rental market New
York also has rent control did that work
depends on whose side you're on
but but but I haven't not be a fan of
rent control ok fine ok so I actually
remember like I've been saying over and
over that I've actually believed that
there are collective problems we need to
collectively solve them together and
what rent control does is it it makes
individual landlords responsive I'm
going to give you two different sizes
answers but it makes individual rule
Anwar is responsible depending on on the
age of their tenants a variety of other
factors at least in New York as to
whether the rent is affordable or not
and I feel that's an inappropriate
burden on on specific it's not a
universally to apply thing it ends up
being spottily applied on the other hand
what I also deeply believe in it was
called affordable housing preservation
today more so there are buildings that
are in affordable housing programs that
are coming to the end of their life that
are aging out there are buildings that
we call naturally occurring affordable
they may be in a nice neighborhood in
the Bronx that are lower rent or that
used to be in Potrero Hill that we're
lower rent and we can design programs
and our company this is one of the
largest growth areas of our company we
actually buy these buildings we preserve
their affordability we make them greener
we bring social services the residents
and we can do that with financing in a
way that makes it profitable and is this
also then help maintain sort of
continuity in the neighborhood because
that seems to be one of the essences of
good city life is that it doesn't change
out from under you a lot where you live
yes so one of it
one of the cheapest ways to provide
affordable housing is to preserve the
affordable housing we have and to invest
in it to make sure that it's safe
doesn't have led that it doesn't have
mold that it's green clean and and then
surrounded by the other elements of
community of opportunity that I
mentioned so we not only need great
affordable housing we need great schools
health care all the other come on let's
talk about schools because it pattern we
see all over the world as I can tell is
that you know the per square foot value
of downtown and their downtown becomes
so high that once the family starts
having children right they're gonna go
to the suburbs and we have the San
Francisco phenomenon of a lot of
high-tech companies that are startup
mode or in the city right and they got
red-hot coders moving from one of them
the sense they want to settle down they
go get a job at Apple or Google or some
laid-back you know family oriented
company and they go suburban what I know
of those companies those people work
pretty hard and no question of working
hard
ed logged but but the schools they're
looking for or they are not here so
that's interesting San Francisco problem
interestingly in New York City we are
increasingly growing public school
options charter school options and
private school options so that more and
more families are staying in that many
families are staying in the city we're
actually seeing it interesting phenomena
which an inflow of grandparents who are
retiring to be and moving to the city to
be near their grandkids that would be
cool so that we that's it that's by the
way not just in New York that is a
growing urban phenomena that we're
people used to retire and go to work all
the sand states Florida in Arizona yeah
right Southern California now they're
retiring to cities to be near their
grandkids does this mean hmm I mean but
the ideal school as I understand it is a
school that you feel okay about your kid
walking to school it's close enough and
they're safe enough that that can happen
walking so I'm gonna give you an
interesting example that's in the book
actually so in 1970 there's great school
desegregation
order and I contrast what happened in
two cities so in check in Detroit there
was a huge protest against it actually
the John Birch Society burned the school
buses the city at that time was 80%
white 20% black after desegregation the
white soul moved to the suburbs city of
Detroit is now 96% minority and the
schools we know what's happened 'try
it's done very very poorly Louisville
Kentucky a southern city actually took a
different tack to the same desegregation
order they they said we're gonna combine
our city and county school system so you
can't move and get away from it we're
gonna make every school under the same
rule and therefore we have a commitment
to making every school equally good
that's that's we're all in it together
so it doesn't matter whether you're in
the city or the suburb inner city
wealthy neighborhood they're all gonna
be as equal decided this because the
other strong mayor or what happened they
actually decided because of the
leadership of two families the big young
family which owned the newspaper and the
TV stations etcetera steam and the
foreman family the brown family which
owned brown-forman the biggest employer
in town and the kind of brown-forman
liquor company those the civic leaders
so it sounds like the evil folks right
you know the company channel and this
worked so well that about a decade ago
the city and county governments merged
they just said and what has happened
here you do that you can do that by the
way the first city to do was
Indianapolis did this and they called it
I've heard it's not the great
convergence that's a name for it anyway
they did it and I think the late 80s or
early 90s it was very cost-effective the
one out of gain when you merge the city
in the county we have it here but it's
we're on a peninsula it sort of happened
so when you when you merge them then you
don't have a special cost effective you
don't have you know all this duplication
but you get this one you get regional
cooperation so let's go back to
Louisville so what happened is now all
of a sudden you have a region community
great school system well all of a sudden
by the way talk about busing what
happens if
best school is in a poor neighborhood
but you really want your kids to go to
is the best school and it's a little far
away you want your kids bussed there
they completely change the psychology
everything so now let's talk about two
decades later what happened Louisville
has one of the lowest unemployment rates
in the country and one of the reasons
why is because they generate these great
young people who make fantastic
employees because there are people who
have grown up with diversity and they
stay in town and they stay in town but
what's happening now is that companies
from all around the world who want to
settle into a low cost environment look
around and they see Louisville and they
see that they have these very
high-functioning young people coming out
of the school system and so it's turned
out to be a great economic boon the
point is that that this school issue is
a very very important issue I think we
need to solve it with the approach that
we're all in it together we're gonna
make every school great I like that bill
the seas around the schools like you're
on absolutely the right track thank you
for showing us the way here thank you so
much
[Applause]
[Music]
you